more than 200 million people have been
infected by the coronavirus recently the
world has seen a rise in the cases
because of the delta variant
less people are willing to take their
jabs as there are claims that the
vaccines aren't effective against this
variant
but is this really true
to check this out we have come to the
university clinic in bonn which is one
of the biggest hospitals in germany
we'll be talking to leading doctors here
and try to understand how the delta
variant is affecting the coronavirus
cases in germany
dr jens christianshever works in the
intensive care unit he says among those
admitted to the hospitals with the delta
variant only very few have been fully
vaccinated
currently
we face only patients without any
vaccinations which is probably also
caused by
in the situation that we didn't have
vaccinations available in the first and
second wave but when you look down or
when you look back to the last weeks
then we face only patients without
vaccination
does a full vaccination still protect
against the delta variant here is what
some people say on social media
ruin someone's day using only four words
the vaccine doesn't work
some say the covet vaccines are not
working at all
false
the latest numbers show that recorded
cases of a delta variant in germany make
up 97
of all covet cases
the number of hospitalizations is higher
for this variant than it was for the
initial one
covet vaccines offer 100 protection from
the delta variant
faults
according to experts and scientific
evidence there are three main reasons
why some people who have been fully
vaccinated can still be at risk of
serious illness or even death due to the
delta variant
looking at the efficacy rate of the
vaccines we see that none of them offer
a hundred percent protection against
covet 19.
dr
swaminathan is currently the chief
scientist at the world health
organization
she says all the corona vaccines help
against the delta variant
they all do protect against getting
infected to varying degrees across the
different vaccines
but what's really important is that
all of them protect against severe
disease
one reason for a low efficacy is that
there are people with a low immune
response
the immune response
varies from individual to individual and
it's impacted by a number of factors
and age is one of those factors as
in very young children and very old
people the immune responses are usually
quite a weaker than
they would be in a healthy adult
underlying illnesses
and other risk factors
can also impact the immune response
reason number two is that vaccinated
individuals jabs can lack efficacy if
they take specific medicines
people who have received
immunosuppressive therapy or have had
transplants do not respond quite as well
to the vaccine
despite the high efficacy of the
approved vaccines experts assume there
is a veining effect
therefore a third reason is that the
efficacy of the vaccination weakens with
time
will examine
[Music]
the currently approved covet vaccines do
not offer enough protection against the
delta variant
false the best chances of avoiding
hospitalization or a deadly course off
the delta variant is by getting a full
vaccination the numbers vary in the
trials and real life studies in various
countries
the data currently available for the
vaccines approved by the eu shows that
they offer a very high protection
according to a canadian study the
effectiveness of the biontech pfizer
vaccination against the delta variant in
terms of completely preventing infection
is at 56 percent after the first jab and
at 87 after the full vaccination
according to the same study the moderna
vaccine shows high protection from the
delta variant of 72 percent after the
first dose
however there is not enough data to show
how high the protection is after two
jabs
according to a uk study people
vaccinated with astrazeneca are 71
protected after the first vaccination
and 92 percent after the second
johnson and johnson itself claims that
its vaccine produced a strong immune
response
however no precise figures have been
provided and there is no independent
data yet
all experts interviewed by dw are
convinced that the vaccines are
effective against the delta variant the
vaccination is a very good tool
but it's not the only tool that we have
to control this infection and it's good
to continue with those personal
protective measures for some time to
come
these first studied results indicate
that the delta variant is more resistant
to the vaccines but a full vaccination
continues to provide strong protection
even against this variant
have you seen online misinformation
about covet 19 or the vaccines that we
should check
let us know in the comments below or
send us an email to factchecking dw.com
[Music]